sometimes when you're in a hotel or any
place you're going to be for a long time
you could run into the guy countless
times you know repetitionally
and so this fell i'm at this hotel the
second day and this guy
says what's up he's uh
he's a nice guy being real friendly
and
um
and then finally he goes hey man
the conversation had kind of gotten
where there wasn't much left to say
which is okay that's when you everybody
kind of goes their separate ways
and he goes hey man i'm gonna give you
uh
i'm gonna give you six guesses what my
name is and i'm like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
because i don't want to do that
i don't want that man
i'm i don't want that
you know i don't want
i want no guesses how many how much what
names the man is
but
you know i guess there
there's a part of me that likes games i
guess so
i said
alex and uh
and he goes no but that's close
and he goes i'll give you three extra
guesses and i'm like oh [ __ ] dude
i don't want that
i don't want that man
i don't want that extra guesses
i don't so now i have nine guesses minus
one now i have eight guesses what this
guy's name is and i don't want no
guesses
um so anyway he goes and you don't have
to guess again right now i'll see you
around the way right because he worked
at the place
so dude i kept
i ran into this guy
i ran into this guy
uh
a lot i mean i ran into this guy 30 more
times over the week
and it was just a nightmare and finally
you know i guess like i did like two
other guesses because there was you know
one day i had already done my wordle or
whatever and so i was like i need a game
to play and he [ __ ] wandered up and
he always wandered up
i mean he would wander up on a damn wind
you know i mean somebody would cough a
few feet away and he'd
he'd wander right up out of their damn
esophagus this dude wandered up you know
he was the kind of guy that wandered up
so finally i'm trying to guess and uh
i'm like tyler is it tyler um the guy
tells me that his name is galaxy
and that's why alex was close
and at that point i knew
it was time to leave man
it was time to leave bro that's when
that's when it's time to go
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one